[Musique]
les ingénieurs de bombardier ont planché
pendant des années sur leur projet de
créer un nouvel avion de ligne à la fine
pointe de la technologie et ils ont
réussi c'est la cseries maintenant
devenu l'airbus à 220 revoyons
l'histoire de cet appareil exceptionnel
septembre 2021 air france klm dévoile
son premier airbus 1 220 le premier des
60 unités qu'il ajoutera sa flotte c'est
gênant est absolument formidable la
gamme à 220 et nul autre que la cseries
conçus par bombardier
mais dans airbus
akil programme aujourd'hui quelque 650
commandes fermes composent le carnet de
livraison de la 220
si les ventes sont au rendez vous
rappelons que l'histoire de la cseries a
connu son lot de turbulences
le bourget france juin 2015
après onze ans de développement la
cseries de bombardier fait ses premiers
pas sur la scène internationale
l'appareil peut accueillir entre 100 et
150 passagers merveille la technologie à
plusieurs égards
avec peu de moyens qu'on a seulement
bardet et d'inventer d'arriver à mettre
un avion comme ça sans sur le marché
c'est extraordinaire
fassi kafyeke est aérodynamicien il
conçoit les avions du futur
pour la naissance de la cseries
l'objectif est clair on cherche la forme
parfaite celle qui produira le moins de
traînée possible
l'aérodynamicien essaye toujours de
maximiser l'importance est de minimiser
la traînée parce que la trainée doit
être combattue par les moteurs et donc
plus si a traîné plus si la consommation
de carburant plus fort mais du carbone
dans l'atmosphère
pour trouver la forme parfaite les
ingénieurs construisent des maquettes
qu'il teste en allemagne ça ça nous
permet de réduire les incertitudes et ça
nous a aidés évidemment à tenir les
performances de l'avion que nous avions
promis donc dès le départ vous saviez
que vos calculs étaient bons oui c'est
ça on savait à partir des résultats de
souffle au risque que l'avion frein en
val
l'appareil est équipé d'elle d'une
nouvelle génération
mais cette nouveauté pose un problème
ses ailes sont transmis qu
c'est à dire qu'au dessus d'elle l'air
atteint des vitesses supersoniques
cela provoque des turbulences et
occasionne de la traîner mais on a
réussi à avoir je pense une aile
transonic qui a une finesse c'est à dire
un rapport portant ce trait n'est parmi
les plus élevés dans les avions aux
roues
pour maximiser ses performances on doit
réduire le poids de l'appareil la
solution la fibre de carbone
bombardier développe à son usine de
belfast en irlande du nord une nouvelle
technique l'infusion de matériaux
composites dans les longerons avant
arrière sont en carbone les revêtements
de pau externes et internes extrados
intrados sont en carbone tous les volets
sont en composite des ailerons et les
winglet sont en composites
pour atteindre les performances
souhaitées il manque une pièce maîtresse
le moteur
par chance pour bombardier le motoriste
pratt & whitney travaille depuis 25 ans
sur son nouveau moteur
développé conjointement avec la nasa la
nouvelle turbine a coûté 10 milliards de
dollars américains
voici son fonctionnement dans un avion à
réaction normalement l'air chaud de la
turbine est la principale source de
propulsion avec la turbine de pratt &
whitney si le contraire c'est surtout
l'air froid générés par les balles à
l'intérieur de la nacelle qui fait
avancer l'avion et l'air froid passe à
l'extérieur passe par là voilà il fait
le tour dont il passe de ce côté de ce
côté tout autour on à nous donc on a 90
% de la poussée qui est générée en fait
par leur froid par rapport à la à la
poussée qui est générée par l'air chaud
et ça permet de diminuer la consommation
carburant énormément
résultat le moteur bruit moins de
carburant c'est l'un des moins polluants
sur le marché
autre avantage le bruit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les moteurs de la cseries sont 34% plus
silencieux que ses concurrents c'est
l'avion le plus silencieux de sa
catégorie
avant d'embarquer ses premiers passagers
la cseries a dû obtenir sa certification
auprès de transports canada
c'est d'étaples plus difficiles de son
histoire
[Musique]
les essais de certification ou duré plus
de deux ans
pendant les essais aux tortures l'avion
on provoque des pannes de moteur et on
fait voler à travers des nuages
verglaçants
tomas maier et membre de l'équipe qui
coordonne ces essais on veut aller
démontré que l'appareil au des systèmes
de sécurité qui vont aller à prévenir
qu'un accident arrive advenant le cas où
on va au delà des limites des systèmes
de l'appareil ou de la vallée
la cseries comprend cinq avions d'essais
ingénieur de vol nicolas d'amnesty
travail dans la rue deux
vous avez bien sûr noté la couleur
orange qui revient à partout dans cet
avion c'est simple tout ce qui est
orange et expérimental on n'a pas
cherché l'esthétique ici on a cherché
juste le fonctionnel
en tout l'avion est soumis à plus de
8000 test
la majorité des essais sont hors vols
les certains se font au sol
pour le test de l'eau on a construit une
piscine sur la piste au bord d'une
piscine avec 4 pouces d'eau sur
plusieurs mètres et on va faire à
différentes vitesses que ce soit 60 80
100 jusqu'à 120 ne on va faire accélérer
l'avion à travail
et puis le but c'est un de prouver on
est capable de garder le contrôle de
l'appareil lorsque ça arrive et la
deuxième c'est l'angle de projection de
l'eau pour s'assurer que l'eau surtout
n'entre pas dans les moteurs pourrait
causer une panne matin
la plupart des tests ont été faits à
mirabel mais certains l'ont été aux
états unis site ici en floride qu'ont
fait les essais de froid extrême
ce hangar est un immense congélateur
on immobilise l'avion en baisse ensuite
la température à moins 50 degrés celsius
une fois l'appareil congelés olemps les
moteurs pour s'assure qu'il démarre
[Musique]
les essais sont évalués en fonction de
leur niveau de dangerosité
le test de vélocité minimale est l'un
des plus risqués
alors un test qui est très spectaculaire
où on va diminuer les vitesses et puis
on va déterminer exactement la vitesse
minimale que l'avion peut décoller
[Applaudissements]
l'avion avant si lentement quel patins
installé à l'arrière du fuselage
touchent la piste
malgré les flammèches il finit par
s'arracher du sol
pour le test de freinage d'urgence
équipage est en alerte maximale
au sol les pompiers sont aux aguets
[Musique]
alors le test encore le plus critique
c'est le test qu'on appelle d'énergie
kinetic maximum sait où on va mettre le
maximum de poids dans l'avion le maximum
de carburant on va aller jusqu'à la
vitesse de décollage et on va aussi
voulu ou non le fond de faire pour de
vrai un freinage d'urgence et ça c'est
un autre testé ce pigment très dangereux
la chaleur est si grand que l'ip nous
éclater
mais au moins cela fonctionne
à l'origine pratt & whitney promettait
16% d'économies carburant dans les faits
la cseries consomment aujourd'hui 25 %
moins de carburant
bombardier est convaincu que ses
concurrents ne parviendront pas à égaler
les performances de la cseries
octobre 2010 est la cseries est en
service depuis plus d'un an le marché
demeure prudent si prudent que la
cseries est un échec commercial et ce
malgré ses qualités indéniables
en grande difficulté financière
bombardier doit se résigner il cède la
cseries à airbus
aussitôt ce dernier la rebaptise à 220